I'm in midtown Manhattan at Broadway and
54th outside the Ed Sullivan Theater
which CBS bought for Dave Letterman back
in 1993 the network paid four million
dollars for the building a few million
more for renovations and accounting for
inflation that's still a steel
in 1992 CBS hired Dave Letterman away
from NBC faced a big decision keep
Letterman in New York or move him to Los
Angeles where there were newer bigger
studios New York offered incentives to
keep Letterman here and CBS picked this
theater an historic landmark building
once home to ed Sullivan's Sunday night
variety show it is where the Beatles
first performed on live TV in the US it
was a big deal for a network to buy a
whole building for a late-night talk
show this is all about symbolism we see
it as a restoration of a theater and
renewal and revitalization for a network
and even for the city
it certainly coincided with the
Renaissance the rebirth of Times Square
just a few blocks south with Letterman's
show and residents the Ed Sullivan
Theater became a tourist attraction and
monthly rents have gone up dramatically
since 1993
back then it was around 33 bucks a
square foot now it's more than doubled
to just over $72 every time one of these
shows changes hands New York and Los
Angeles Duke it out last year New York
offered CBS 11 million dollars worth of
state tax credits five million dollars
in grants to keep the Late Show in New
York Stephen Colbert takes over the Late
Show on September 8th in a building
that's not worth many millions more than
what CBS paid for it back in 1993